getting to know her has been so special
because I'm Blown Away by her she is in
my opinion she is the one to watch no
one is more excited about ice spice's
feature on the new Karma remix than
Taylor Swift herself I keep meeting new
people life continues to be inspiration
the Grammy winner dropped the updated
version of karma on Friday
[Music]
Ann Taylor explained how the whole thing
came to be during a chat with Spotify
she reached out through her team just
kind of saying hey you know ice has been
a big fan of Taylor's since she was a
little kid would love to collaborate if
that was ever something that came about
and I had been listening to her non-stop
like getting ready for my tours so I
immediately got her number and said hey
would you want to do you know your
version of karma do you relate to this
and so she jumped in head first I'll be
dragging that wagon karma is a beauty
[Music]
Taylor confirmed the rapper's
involvement on Instagram just one day
prior to the release writing that she's
a massive fan of the brilliant artist in
my opinion she is the one to watch just
watching her work ethic and how
thoughtfully she approaches her career
she's like my new favorite artist and
I'm so honored that she's on the song so
yeah what a joy
Bounty Hunter and Coleman's gonna track
you down step by step from town to town
following Taylor's announcement ice
called Tay the sweetest person ever and
on Friday she shared this pic from the
studio I love it of course ice is having
a great year she scored a major hit with
boys a liar part two
making fun of me
like that boys
[Music]
and collaborated with Nicki Minaj on
Princess Diana and I just fell in love
with that gangster so he put my name in
the top but I don't let him come to the
crib
that track dropped to the same month she
played a massive bash at Coachella and
ice made her Mech Gala debut
oh and let's not forget her Mega viral
Tick Tock collab with Kim Kardashian's
daughter Northwest but I don't sleep
enough without you and I can't eat
enough without you if you don't speak
does that mean we're through don't like
snake that you do I don't know what's
gonna top that we can't wait to see what
ice does next in fact we smell a Grammy
in her future and until then we'll be
here rocking out to the remix of karma
keeping our fingers crossed for a
surprise appearance on Taylor's eras
World Tour
foreign
[Music]